[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans la nouvelle
formule du 7 8 c'est votre émission pour
bien démarrer la soirée dans les
Yvelines avec au programme de
l'actualité des infos pratiques et des
idées de sortie bonsoir Mathilde bonsoir
Nicolas vous êtes Paris pour cette
nouvelle tranche d'information
un plaisir d'inaugurer cette nouvelle
émission avec exactement et puis en plus
on va parler politique puisque il y a
encore des Yvelines qui ont voté
certains en tout cas ce week-end
justement on jette tout de suite un coup
d'oeil au programme de ce 10 octobre
avec ce sommet et les électeurs de la
deuxième circonscription qui ont tranché
Jean-Noël Barrault remporte l'élection
législative partielle il a été réélu
avec
71,67% des voix devant Maïté caribbeani
de la nupaise déjà membre du
gouvernement le ministre va céder son
siège à sa suppléante Anne Bergans qui
deviendra député pour la première fois
elle est notre invité près d'une
station-service sur trois connaîtrait
des difficultés d'approvisionnement en
France une situation tendue également
dans les Yvelines où trouver du
carburant relève du parcours du
combattant nous ferons le point et vous
verrez que cette actualité nous impacte
nous aussi journalistes et puis côté
sport c'est l'événement fort de ce mois
d'octobre à 50 ans en Yvelines le
vélodrome national accueille les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste c'est du 12 au 16 octobre 50
délégations 25000 spectateurs attendus
pour cet événement
comme un test grandeur nature des Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 et sur cette
actualité d'ailleurs on recevra tout à
l'heure en plateau Jean-Michel richefort
qui est vice-président de la Fédération
Française de Cyclisme sport toujours
avec les résultats sportifs du week-end
et on prendra des nouvelles de nos clubs
de football Yves Linois qui était
engagés dans le 5e tour de la Coupe de
France
[Musique]
mes coups de demain dans les Yvelines ce
11 octobre jour de la saint Firmin il
fera plutôt nuageux compter 9 degrés le
matin avec pas mal de nuages annoncés ce
sera 15 degrés l'après-midi voilà vous
le voyez un œuf degré très nuageux le
matin 15° dans l'après-midi dans les
Yvelines des nuages également annoncés
pour le reste de la semaine dans le
département la pluie devrait même
s'inviter par moments à partir de jeudi
au niveau des températures ça ne devrait
pas descendre en dessous des 13 degrés
les informations du jour c'est tout de
suite dans le 7 8
[Musique]
avec Mathilde Franco à la une de
l'actualité Mathilde c'est l'essence qui
fait parler au niveau national qui fait
parler aussi dans les Yvelines faire son
plein justement dans le département ça
s'apparente à un calvaire
et
des heures à voir si oui ou non il
restera suffisamment de carburant pour
sa voiture ce week-end une station sur
deux était fermée car non approvisionné
la grève dans les raffineries est
d'ailleurs reconduite le préfet des
Yvelines a également interdit la vente
et l'achat de l'essence dans les bidons
les jerricanes j'en parlais dans les
titres à la une de l'actualité également
c'est cette législative partielle
élection législative partielle avec le
résultat du second tour dans la deuxième
circonscription et Jean-Noël barreau
l'emporte largement oui hier soir le
ministre délégué au numérique a été élu
à
71,67% dans la deuxième circonscription
des Yvelines face à la candidat de la
nupes m'a été cariffe bedouani déjà au
gouvernement elle va passer la main à sa
suppléante Anne bergante mais le grand
gagnant de cette élection reste
l'abstention seulement 26,17% des
votants se sont déplacés aux urnes nous
sommes en octobre le 10 octobre et
octobre c'est le mois du dépistage du
cancer du sein le maobus est de retour
dans les Yvelines exactement à
l'occasion d'Octobre Rose une tournée de
dépistage gratuit du cancer du sein est
organisé dans le département le 11
octobre le maobus sera à Versailles le
12 à La Verrière le 24 au Mureaux le 27
à Chanteloup-les-Vignes et le 5 novembre
à Houdan en 2018
58500 femmes ont pu être diagnostiqués
en France une prise en charge d'eau
augmente les chances de guérison
acrobate clown magicien je ne parle pas
des talents cachés de Nicolas dandry
mais bien du 20e Festival International
du Cirque des Mureaux il a encore battu
des records ce weekend oui elles étaient
une dizaine d'artistes à venir présenter
leurs talents aux Mureaux venant de Cuba
d'Italie ou encore d'Ukraine ils ont
enflammé la reine on écoute Godefroy
effectivement c'est la première fois que
je participe au festival cirque des
Mureaux c'est familial festif qui a un
plateau d'artistes extraordinaire du
monde entier donc c'est même un honneur
de 10 participants on en entend parler
dans le milieu artistique dans le milieu
du cirque et ouais c'est super d'être là
aujourd'hui
et fini les animaux sauvages les lions
et les tigres ne sont plus autorisés
depuis deux ans mais avec 8000
spectateurs environ durant le week-end
la fête à tout de même battue son plein
Nicolas vous vouliez réagir parce que je
vois que dès le début de la saison vous
carburez au bonne blague Grégory non
mais c'est histoire de mettre une bonne
ambiance sur ce plateau justement on va
parler de sport avec du football ce
week-end avait lieu le 5e tour de la
Coupe de France effectivement à Grégory
et c'est la fin de l'aventure pour le FC
Montois ils se sont inclinés de A0 face
au club de National Paris 13 Athletico
sur les cinq clubs yvelinois engagés de
son corps en lice pour le 6e tour les
détails tout à l'heure avec notre
journaliste sportif Michael elle lui
demande qui sera tout à l'heure avec
nous en plateau
[Musique]
merci Mathilde et vous le disiez à la
une de l'actualité du jour c'est le
second tour de cette élection
législative partielle qui s'est tenue
dans la deuxième circonscription des
Yvelines avec nous en plateau de nos a
rejoints bonsoir vous étiez merci d'être
présente avec nous alors vous étiez la
candidate suppléante de Jean-Noël
Barrault et vous avez remporté ce
scrutin c'est vous d'ailleurs un qui
siègerez à l'Assemblée nationale en tant
que député puisqu'on rappelle que
Jean-Noël Barraud est déjà membre du
gouvernement il est le ministre de la
transition numérique et aux
télécommunications on va parler avec
vous de ce nouveau rôle de ce qui vous
attend et comment vous allez aborder
cette nouvelle fonction mais d'abord
Nicolas dandry qui est avec moi
également en plateau qui est avec nous
et on va revenir sur les résultats de
ces élections et je le disais une
victoire assez large de Jean-Noël
Barrault effectivement Grégory Jean-Noël
Barrault candidat de la majorité
présidentielle a obtenu 71,7% des voix
c'est donc une large victoire pour
l'actuel ministre un nouveau succès
certes mais à relativiser d'abord par
rapport au chiffre de l'abstention qui
dépasse la les 70% des inscrits c'est
largement supérieur aussi au 45% atteint
au second tour le 19 juin dernier lors
de la précédente élection législative
cette faible participation a donc eu
aussi des conséquences sur les résultats
si on poursuit la comparaison le taux
est beaucoup plus important aujourd'hui
puisque il était à 64 % en juin dernier
mais Jean-Noël Barrault perd plus de
15000 électeurs dans cette élection
partielle qui a eu lieu hier et le
phénomène et le même pour Maïté qui
arrive bedouani la candidate écologiste
de la nups a récolté 28,3% des suffrages
ce dimanche 9 octobre soit 5000
bulletins glissés dans l'urne avec son
nom mais c'est 10000 de moins par
rapport à juin dernier et d'ailleurs on
écoute la réaction de Maïté qu'arrive
Benoît ni suite au résultat d'hier soir
c'est une élection
qui porte Anne bergance à l'Assemblée
nationale
avec moins de 15%
des habitants inscrits dans cette
élection nous avons pu observer une
campagne sur médiatisée côté
Jean-Noël Barrault à la fois
mobilisation des ministres de la presse
de la télévision et de moyens
ciblés et pour élire finalement une
personne qui ne sera pas Jean-Noël
Barrault moi je veux pas dire que je
suis dans la défaite puisque déjà nous
représentons une force alternative
alors on voit votre adversaire Anne
bercante commenter le chiffre de
l'abstention finalement et puis aussi
dire que finalement les électeurs de la
seconde circonscription des Yvelines ont
voté pour Jean-Noël Barrault et non pas
pour vous comme on comment vous
réagissez par rapport à ses propos alors
on peut pas évidemment se satisfaire du
taux d'abstention mais qui nous concerne
nous et qui nous concerne également m'a
été qu'arrive l'édouani ça n'est pas
vraiment une surprise puisque dans des
élections législatives partielles on
tourne toujours à peu près autour de 25%
de participation donc on est un petit
peu en deçà donc ça n'est pas vraiment
une surprise on n'a pas l'effet moteur
que peut avoir une élection nationale on
était les seuls à voter en fait en
France pendant ces deux derniers
week-end
ça pose évidemment la question de
l'écart peut-être qui grandit aussi
entre les électeurs et nous et toute la
question de savoir comment on peut
ramener les jeunes dans les débats
publics et leur donner envie en votant
mais pas que en participant à la vie
la vie civile elle vit politique
en général de pouvoir s'investir
néanmoins hormis cette abstention
effectivement on peut dire qu'on nous
avons été largement élus avec Jean-Noël
barreau donc les résultats des urnes ne
portent pas à discussion en ce qui
concerne le fait que ce sera moi qui
siègera effectivement la suppléante je
suis toujours un petit peu étonnée de
l'interrogation puisque en fait au mois
de juin c'était le cas beaucoup de
ministres qui se représentaient en
législatif et ça ne posait visiblement
pas de questions là en l'occurrence ça
en pose parce que c'est voilà on est un
peu sous les feux de la rampe étant la
seule élection mais pour moi ça n'est
pas un sujet c'est la règle en fait il y
a un titulaire une suppléante titulaire
étant ministre ça n'était pas caché
évidemment pendant cette élection je
deviens député tant qu'il est ministre
et il reprendra évidemment son poste de
député si
le président de la République en décide
alors pour vous présenter underground
vous êtes élu à Lévis un nom depuis 14
ans c'est la commune dont anne-grignon
est le maire on rappelle juste que
c'était l'ex député suppléante de
Jean-Noël Barrault qui était devenu
député justement à l'entrée de Jean-Noël
Barrault au gouvernement sur un cours
laps de temps parce qu'il avait dû
démissionner elle cumulait également la
fonction de sénatrice suppléante des
Yvelines elle pouvait pas cumuler donc
les deux fonctions vous êtes dans vos
activités professionnelles responsables
du service social auprès des patients
d'un hôpital public parisien juste une
petite pression du coup cette carrière
professionnelle pour le moment va être
mise de côté avec ces nouvelles
fonctions de débuter oui oui absolument
j'ai demandé ma disponibilité alors vous
vous le savez sans doute c'est qu'il y a
un délai de carence là qui s'applique
donc je ne suis pas aujourd'hui députée
je serai député dans 30 jours et j'ai
demandé ma mise en disponibilité c'est
une chance que j'ai de pouvoir le faire
mais je voilà je travaille encore
jusqu'au bout dans dans
dans cet hôpital à Paris quotidiennement
c'est pour ça que dans la présentation
ne soyez pas étonné pour les
téléspectateurs c'est bien marqué futur
député des Yvelines pourquoi cet
engagement politique à côté de votre
carrière professionnelle je dis il y a
un engagement déjà dans une commune les
villes saint noment depuis 14 ans
j'allais presque dire que j'avais déjà
un engagement plutôt dans la vie
publique plutôt que dans la vie
professionnelle j'ai un parcours un peu
professionnel un peu atypique j'ai fait
une école de commerce j'ai travaillé
dans le secteur marchand je me suis
arrêté de nombreuses années pour élever
mes enfants j'ai trois enfants
et puis pendant ce laps de temps je me
suis engagée dans l'associatif et dans
la vie communale donc vous l'avez dit
depuis 2008 en temps concernant
municipal ensuite adjointe
aux affaires associatives aux affaires
scolaires ce qui est présente voilà des
sujets que j'aime voilà qui m'intéresse
particulièrement et puis de nouveau
conseiller municipal depuis 2020 parce
que c'était l'époque où je
faisais une réorientation
professionnelle voilà qui m'a amené à
décider de ne plus mettre mes adjointe
parce que on le sait ce sont des voilà
des fonctions qui sont très qui demande
un investissement très important
et j'ai souhaité donc c'était un petit
peu quelques années plus tôt en 2014
reprendre des études plus en lien avoir
un métier qui est du sens voilà pour moi
et j'ai repris des études assistantes
sociales donc j'ai été diplômée en 2017
et en deux voilà donc
en 2018 j'ai j'ai commencé ma carrière
au sein de l'hôpital
et je suis actuellement Responsable de
Service Social donc j'avais d'abord une
vie je dirais
investi dans l'intérêt général
une vie professionnelle qui est arrivée
plus tard et mais tout ceci est assez
cohérent finalement dans l'intérêt
général qui évolue du commune vous
passez donc à une circonscription vous
allez devenir je le disais député de
cette deuxième circonscription pourquoi
vous avez accepté de vous joindre à
Jean-Noël Barrault pour pour ses
élections et de devenir du coup député
par la suite c'est évidemment pas une
décision qu'on prend à la légère tenter
l'implique des des choix personnels
professionnels je connais Jean-Noël
Barrault évidemment depuis 2017 depuis
qu'il est député la circonscription
c'est un député qui a toujours été
extrêmement présent sur les territoires
et qui a œuvré je dirais sur des sujets
sensibles notamment sur ma commune mais
aussi sur la vallée de de Chevreuse je
sais pour l'avoir côtoyer régulièrement
que nous partageons des valeurs communes
et
sans revenir sur les événements de cet
été en fait
voilà c'est un peu tout naturellement je
pense qu'il s'est adressé à moi je il
recherchais une élue du Sud de la
circonscription c'était déjà un choix
une femme parce que la parité qui n'est
pas imposée effectivement dans le ticket
lui semblait importantes
et donc il m'a proposé je suis
évidemment
honorée de la confiance qu'il m'a faite
et après quelques temps de réflexion
j'ai décidé d'accepter parce que c'est
une aventure qui enfin qui ne peut pas
se refuser en fait qui ne veut pas se
refuser dans une circonscription
particulière qui est à cheval sur
l'urbain sur sur le rural avec un
territoire pluriel on peut le dire il y
a les cantons de Vélizy Versailles Sud
ça va également jusqu'à Chevreuse quels
sont les sujets importants à vos yeux
dans cette circonscription
circonscription pardon que vous
souhaitez porter au niveau national
alors ça c'est une très bonne question à
laquelle je vais pas pouvoir forcément
répondre je connais les chantiers qui
ont été initiés par Jean-Noël Barraud et
que je vais
je vais continuer évidemment donc il y a
des sujets liés vous le savez aux
nuisances sonores notamment des sujets
locaux mais qui ont abouti à des
législation et un il y a des lois au
niveau de l'Assemblée nationale c'est
aussi le sujet de tous sur le noble avec
son avec les nuisances sonores aussi
liées à son activité
les sujets liés
à la ligne 18 qui sont enfin qui est un
sujet important l'un des tronçons va
passer justement sur le plateau
Magny-les-Hameaux château fort donc
c'est des sujets de d'infrastructures
moi qui me semble important de continuer
à porter surtout aujourd'hui quand on
parle enfin les transports en commun me
semble un élément important si on
réfléchit sur les mobilités et notamment
sur le réchauffement climatique aussi
il y a aussi d'autres sujets sur une
nuisance sonore aussi sur la 86 sur des
pôles vers Versailles et sur Vélizy
ensuite j'ai envie de vous dire j'ai
l'intention d'être aussi présente que
Jean-Noël Barrault sur le terrain et que
ces sujets là ils sont venus du terrain
donc probablement qu'il y a des sujets
qui que je porterai mais qui sont à
venir très rapidement savoir ressembler
à quoi la ce mois de préparation d'ici
votre prise de fonction officielle du
coup comme député en novembre ça ça va
être vous préparer justement ce rôle oui
oui absolument alors je travaille encore
donc je vais essayer de cumuler alors
d'abord ce sera une présence en
circonscription le week-end évidemment
aux côtés de Jean-Noël Barrault
probablement sur tous les rendez-vous
qu'on peut qu'on peut honorer tout au
long de son de son mandat et puis
évidemment être très très attentif à ce
qui se passe à l'Assemblée sans pouvoir
y participer vous l'avez dit donc il y a
déjà des projets de loi auxquels je sais
que je ne participerai pas de fait mais
par contre avoir une veille plus qu'une
veille en fait une attention quotidienne
sur tous les sujets qui sont portés à
l'Assemblée et voici ce à quoi pourrait
ressembler justement l'une de vos
prochaines journées à l'Assemblée
nationale Nicolas dandry vous avez pu
suivre le temps d'une journée la
présidente du groupe du groupe
Renaissance à l'Assemblée nationale mais
effectivement la député de la dixième
circonscription des Yvelines Aurore
Berger a été élu par son groupe en fait
présidente du groupe Renaissance à
l'Assemblée nationale et bien nous
l'avons suivi le mardi 4 octobre c'était
la semaine dernière et en fait le mardi
c'est une journée très dense pour la
présidente parce que elle participe à la
fois à la réunion de groupe aux
questions aux
gouvernement pardon et prêt à
différentes réunions et vous allez le
voir dans ce reportage la journée est
très dense pour regarder
il est 10h20 Aurore Bergé arrive à
l'Assemblée nationale une rentrée
parlementaire particulière pour
livelinoise pour son second mandat au
Palais Bourbon elle a été élu président
du groupe Renaissance le 22 juin dernier
par les députés du groupe j'ai 170
députés donc 169 autour de moi avec moi
et donc il faut évidemment porter un
collectif ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
définir des lignes des objets politiques
qu'on a envie à un moment de porter dans
le débat public ça définit qui on est et
puis j'oublie pas le territoire
évidemment elle suit d'Yvelines et donc
je continue à arpenter tous les
week-ends
premier rendez-vous la réunion avec les
groupes modèles et horizons qui
composent la majorité présidentielle un
rendez-vous inter-groupe effectué une
fois par mois objectif assurer la
cohésion de la majorité tout en laissant
des marges de manœuvre individuelle aux
députés c'est pas la caserne encore une
fois d'être dans un groupe politique un
choix d'appartenir un groupe politique
c'est un choix d'appartenir à un
collectif et moi ma responsabilité c'est
d'animer le collectif c'est quoi la
ligne qu'est-ce qu'on doit dire moi je
dis voilà ce que je recommande après
chacun est libre parce qu'à la fin
chacun est jugé individuellement aussi
en tant que député et chacun a été élu
individuellement en tant que député pour
occuper cette nouvelle fonction comme la
une de la première victoire d'Emmanuel
Macron affiché dans son bureau Aurore
Berger a osé en général dans la vie
qu'elle soit je pense qu'à un moment il
faut pas attendre qu'on vous donne les
choses il faut y aller il faut oser
prendre la parole il faut oser
s'exprimer il faut aussi avoir de la
cohérence dans les positions qui sont
les mots dans les propositions que vous
portez moi je suis très fière que la
première proposition de loi de mon
groupe ce soit sur la garantie de
l'accès d'IVG pour toutes les femmes et
je crois que s'ils l'ont choisi c'est
parce que peut-être j'avais de
l'expérience du précédent mandat que
j'avais la personnalité qui est la
mienne où ils savent que je peux aller
au combat pour eux que je peux aller au
combat dans l'hémicycle mais que je peux
aussi aller au combat pour obtenir
vis-à-vis du gouvernement un certain
quelque chose combattant elle l'a encore
démontré ce jour-là dans l'hémicycle
Aurore berger à interpeller la première
ministre sur les violences conjugales en
faisant allusion à l'affaire cadenas
depuis plusieurs semaines on fait fier
des règles élémentaires de l'État de
droit
s'il vous plaît je crois que ce sujet
appelle le calme et non le trouble ou le
désordre je crois que ce sujet mérite
mieux que des esclandre et je suis navré
que vous reconnaissiez si bien dans les
propos que j'ai exprimé et pour la
présidente du groupe Renaissance la
tâche ne fait que commencer dans un
contexte de majorité relative une
situation inédite à l'Assemblée
nationale ou le gouvernement et les
groupes de la majorité présidentielle
vont devoir aller chercher des compromis
ou utiliser l'article 49-3 de la
Constitution
alors avant de rentrer dans les détails
pour vous décrire un peu l'ambiance que
j'ai pu constater la semaine dernière à
l'Assemblée nationale d'abord je conclue
sur ce sujet en disant que le
gouvernement va devoir aller chercher
des compromis mais peut-être utiliser
aussi le 49-3 il se trouve que c'est
peut-être d'actualité parce que en ce
moment à l'Assemblée nationale les
députés examinent le projet de loi de
finance en séance publique ça débutera
demain il y a déjà 3511 amendements qui
ont été déposés par les oppositions dont
1192 par les députés les républicains
est-ce que vous vous êtes favorable à
l'utilisation justement de ce 49-3 ou
est-ce que vous justement vous souhaitez
participer à ces débats parlementaires
et les 7 places au députés moi je pense
que il est important de justement
promouvoir le débat parlementaire et que
l'on est d'ailleurs sur ce point nous
devons être exemplaires mais évidemment
participer au départ de mon père c'est
pas forcément privilégier le chaos il
faut que le débat soit constructif je
suis évidemment favorable au débat je
reprendrai ce qu'avait dit Elisabeth
dans sa déclaration poétique générale
compromis n'est pas compromission et le
enfin voilà les échanges restent
indispensables dans un débat
démocratique c'est une évidence alors
justement Grégory je vais revenir sur un
épisode qui m'a assez marqué coulisses
alors déjà si on commence par la matinée
la réunion de groupe qu'on voit ça se
passe une fois par mois c'est-à-dire que
habituellement chaque groupe se réunit
tous les mardis mais là c'était une
réunion intergroupe vous l'avez compris
la majorité présidentielle c'est le
groupe parlementaire horizon c'est le
groupe parlementaire moderne dans lequel
vous allez siéger et c'est le groupe
parlementaire Renaissance donc ça
c'était pour la matinée et puis
l'après-midi moi ce qui m'a marqué c'est
les questions à l'Assemblée nationale
j'ai participé en plusieurs fois pour TV
78 à des questions parlementaires dans
la tribune presse mais là j'ai vu
quelque chose que je n'avais jamais vu
c'est des interruptions sans cesse
première question c'est Marine Le Pen
qui l'a posé sur le fioul la première
ministre a répondu et vraiment sa
réponse et bah tous les députés
du rassemblement national crier et le
fioul et le fuel c'était inaudible
est-ce que vous êtes prêts justement à
cette ambiance assez lourde et assez
pesante et peut-être à des nuits de
débat passer à l'Assemblée nationale
pendant ce quinté ça va se répéter
sûrement sur sur les 5 prochaines années
je peux que le déplorer objectivement
parce que c'est pas du tout mon style
très honnêtement moi je suis je j'estime
que le débat parlementaire doit être un
débat respectueux voilà
par contre je suis évidemment pas
responsable de ce que les autres groupes
estiment de voir faire je pense que on
parlait de l'abstention
je suis pas certaine que ce type de
comportement ail dans le sens de
rapprocher en fait les électeurs
des élus et c'est ce qui menace je
trouve ça très contre-productif à vrai
dire
merci anne-margland c'est d'être venu en
plateau je le rappelle vous avez gagné
donc ce second tour les de la
législative partielle aux côtés de
Jean-Noël Barrault et vous allez sierger
comme député dans un mois député de
cette deuxième circonscription des
Yvelines dans le groupe modem je vais y
arriver merci à Nicolas André également
pour tous ces précisions et nous avoir
fait vivre s'écoulisses à l'Assemblée
nationale merci l'autre actualité du
jour elle est nationale mais a forcément
des répercussions au niveau des Yvelines
ce mouvement social entamé dans les
stations services d'abord dans les
raffineries la grève entamée il y a
quelques jours par les salariés de Total
énergie et des sous-exxon mobile et
reconduite il est donc difficile de
faire le plan en ce moment et c'est le
cas dans le département et Gabriel
Gontier et Julien le roi ont justement
tenté d'aller faire le plein ce matin
regardez
ce lundi encore la pénurie continue dans
les stations services c'est 30% d'après
le gouvernement des stations qui sont
impactées comme de nombreux Français
nous avons besoin d'essence pour aller
travailler nous allons voir comment ça
se passe autour de Guyancourt dans les
Yvelines
les Yvelines font partie des territoires
les plus touchés par la pénurie comme
pour 10 autres départements la
préfecture a pris des mesures pour
éviter la pénurie complète parmi elles
l'interdiction du remplissage de
jerrican on vient tout juste de
s'arrêter à la station de Voisins le
bretonneux comme vous pouvez le voir
derrière moi la file ne désemplie pas
depuis le début de la matinée les stocks
de sans plomb 98 sont déjà à sec en
raison d'une distribution partielle
depuis quelques jours
alors on a repris la route comme vous
pouvez le voir devant nous plus de 200
mètres de queue les automobilistes
commencent à s'impatienter et nous on
arrive dans le rouge je suis arrivé il
était 11h15 donc ça fait quasiment une
heure franchement c'est hallucinant j'ai
jamais vu ça bien que la plupart des
automobilistes comprennent les raisons
de la grève c'est le manque de civisme
de certains à la pompe qui est regretté
sur le principe je le comprends
maintenant je trouve choquant qu'on se
retrouve dans cette situation dans des
queues et dans des pénuries derrière moi
et les gens étaient prêts à se battre
pour une place de dans la ville
ça me semble un peu disproportionné et
vivement que cette situation soit réglée
nous avons enfin atteint la station
Total énergie ici tous les carburants
sont encore disponibles pour le moment à
noter que ce dimanche la première
ministre Elisabeth borne a annoncé que
la situation devrait s'améliorer dans
les jours à venir de son côté total
énergie mis sur la responsabilité de
chacun et prévoit d'avancer les
discussions sous réserve de la fin des
blocages
et on vous le disait une information qui
nous est parvenue dans l'après-midi la
grève et reconduite dans les raffineries
du groupe Total énergie et sceaux et ce
jusqu'à mardi un mouvement qui s'étend
aussi à quelques stations services du
même groupe dans le territoire français
alors comment trouver de l'essence du
carburant dans les Yvelines au-delà du
bouche à oreille plusieurs solutions
s'offrent à vous il y a notamment le
site du gouvernement prix attirer à
carburant.gouv.fr qui propose des mises
à jour tout au long de la journée notez
que le site a été saturé par moment
aujourd'hui et qu'il était impossible
d'y accéder des applications mobiles
également comme Waze ou encore gaspal
qui sont alimentés en temps réel par les
informations des automobilistes tout
comme d'autres sites participative vous
les voyez à l'image le plus connu c'est
mon tiré sans ce point fr via une carte
interactive vous pouvez très facilement
on va pouvoir voir cette cet exemple de
carte facilement accéder également à des
informations sur les stations qui
délivrent du carburant il suffit de
taper dans la barre de recherche une
région un département une ville ou même
un code postal partage également vos
informations sur les comptes Twitter et
Facebook de TV 78 sur la publication en
pénurie de carburant vous pouvez
renseigner dans quelle station-service
et avec quel carburant vous avez pu
faire le plein n'hésitez pas à partager
cette publication pour faire circuler
les informations plus grand nombre
d'automobilistes Vinois on compte sur
vous allez on va parler maintenant
d'actualité sportive dans le département
des Yvelines
[Musique]
avec un nouveau journaliste de la
rédaction de TV 78 c'est Michael el
midro qui m'a rejoint au plateau bonsoir
Michael journaliste sport de la
rédaction de TV 78 ont joué ce week-end
le cinquième tour de la Coupe de France
de football effectivement Grégory
plusieurs clubs divinois étaient encore
en cours ce petit désillusion pour le FC
Mantois 78 qui s'est incliné sur le
score de 2 à 0 face au Paris 13
Athletico des images de Céline charme
le parfum de la Coupe de France flottée
dans l'atmosphère du stade et mébergeal
de Mantes-la-Ville les joueurs locaux du
FC Mantois 78 qui évolue en R1 recevait
le Paris 13 Atlético en club de National
en première période les Parisiens
ouvrent le score sur ce corner avant la
dixième minute de jeu 1 à 0 ce sera le
score à la pose on a pris un but au bout
de 6 minutes donc c'était c'était
difficile mais après on a eu du
répondant c'est en face c'était une
équipe de national qui joue 3 divisions
dessus donc on n'a pas trop à
avoir deux regrets au retour des
vestiaires les visiteurs font le break
suite à ce coup franc après cette
combinaison 2 à 0 quelques minutes plus
tard le FC mantoir récolte un carton
rouge et n'arrivera pas à revenir dans
le match pas de miracle fin de parcours
dans cette Coupe de France 2022-2023
pour le club Ivy noir scénario
catastrophe on prend le bus au bout de
une minute trente donc après c'est
difficile à 2-0 surtout qu'après on
prend un rouge donc il ne restez plus de
35 minutes à jouer à 10 donc après c'est
sûr que c'est toujours plus difficile
franchement la deuxième période on a été
plus tranchant en première période on
était on regardait un peu le ballon on
sortait pas sur le joueur mais en
deuxième parlant on a su se reprendre le
FC Montois va maintenant se focaliser
sur le championnat de régional une le
club evinois est actuellement la 11e
place du classement avec un bilan de
deux nuls et une défaite en trois matchs
c'est bien dommage le FC Mantois éliminé
mais d'autres clubs Yvelines ont été
également lisse pour ce cinquième tour
quels sont les autres résultats les
résultats sont plutôt mitigés à Grégory
pour nos clubs yvelinois le FC Mantois
est donc éliminé on l'a vu Les Mureaux
n'ont pas pu faire mieux et se sont
inclinés trois buts sur le terrain de
Sainte-Geneviève Hardricourt s'est fêté
écraser face à l'ogre Sarcelles sur le
score de 7 buts à deux à domicile Poissy
se qualifier pour le sixième tour sur la
plus petite démarche 1-0 sur le terrain
de Nice sur marne enfin le FC Versailles
le club phare du département remporté
son duel face à Argenteuil 3-1 mais il y
a eu quelques problèmes avec les
supporters adversaires c'est pour ça
qu'il y a marqué voilà le petit reporté
c'était effectivement il y a eu ces
petits problèmes justement c'est c'est
quels sont ces incidences que vous
pouvez vous vous pouvez nous en dire
plus
une fin de match très particulière une
fin de match prématurée des projectiles
et des feux d'artifice ont été lancés
sur le terrain l'arbitre a une première
fois le match mais lors de la reprise
des pétards ont été lancés en direction
du gardien versaillé Sébastien Renaud
suivi d'un envahissement de terrain de
la part des supporters d'Argenteuil
l'arbitre a donc pris la décision de
siffler la fin du match à la 85e minute
score final 3-1 mais Versailles devrait
plutôt avoir match remporté sur tapis
vert au prochain tour Versailles devrait
affronter le Red Star et Poissy jouera
contre Sainte-Geneviève les matchs sont
programmés ce dimanche 16 octobre donc
il reste deux clubs Yvelines ou un
compte est bon c'est bien ça le compte
est bon Grégory on va espérer qu'il
brille sur sur les prochains tours on se
souvient notamment du parcours fabuleux
de Versailles la saison dernière avec
une demi-finale de Coupe de France on va
parler à présent aussi nickel
au Stade de France
on va parler rugby championnat de
fédéral 2 un bon et un mauvais résultat
pour les clubs divino en Fédérale 2 on
va commencer par le bon résultat avec
plaisir qui s'est imposé 32 à 10 sur le
terrain Damien une très belle
performance qui permet au plaisir ou à
d'être quatrième du classement avec
on regarde votre reportage nickel une
équipe de France pour briller à domicile
ce mardi 4 octobre la sélection pour les
Championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste est tombé les spectateurs présents
en Vélodrome national du 12 au 16
octobre pourront voir les têtes
d'affiche françaises comme ryanella
Sébastien vigie ou encore Mathilde gros
ça va être quelque chose de top donc je
me dis voilà j'ai hâte on a encore
quelques jours pour pour peaufiner les
derniers réglages et après bah se lancer
et tout donner devant le public la
famille les amis j'ai fait les Europe
ici en 2016 mais il y avait pas pas les
tribunes pleines donc ça sera un premier
premier championnat domicile avec 6000
personnes derrière moi derrière nous
même pour l'équipe de France on
retrouvera également dans cette équipe
de France trois membres du club local de
50 ans en Yvelines le VCE SkyTeam vous
sert avec Timmy Gillion Quentin Lafargue
et Clara
copponiative du club du coup même si bah
j'ai pas l'occasion de les voir beaucoup
c'est encore plus satisfaisant que de
qui de me dire qu'ils vont être là et
qui vont me voir à la maison et en on a
du monde c'est cool en terme de médaille
les instances n'ont pas voulu chiffrer
d'objectifs pour ce rendez-vous
yvelinois mais l'équipe de France semble
armée pour cet événement on est dans des
disciplines qu'on maîtrise où on a des
favoris de certaines épreuves et surtout
on va courir à domicile encouragé par
par on l'espère un public nombreux et
communicante prendre plaisir à prendre
plaisir alors c'est quelque chose
d'important mais il faut pas se prendre
la tête ou se mettre plus de pression le
gros du travail comme je leur ai dit il
a été fait dans l'année donc il y a une
bonne préparation et après ben faudra
faudra en découdre le jour J pour ce
rendez-vous le vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines affiche
presque complet 25000 personnes sur 5
jours vont pousser cette équipe de
France
et on continue de parler de cet
événement avec Jean-Michel richefort
bonsoir bonsoir vice-président de la
Fédération Française de Cyclisme vous
êtes également le président du club de
l'EC Vélizy 78 une petite question déjà
en réaction à ce sujet on a vu pas
forcément d'objectifs de médaille donnés
par par les Bleus pourquoi tant de
prudence de la part de l'équipe de
France
selon vous on souvient de la Raja de
médailles en 2015 il y avait eu 5
médailles en or 7 médailles au total il
y a aussi d'excellents championnats
d'Europe l'été dernier avec 6 médailles
d'or pour la France avec 15 médailles au
total c'est pas de la fausse modestie de
ne pas se fixer d'objectifs pour ces
Mondiaux à domicile en plus il y a
toujours des objectifs et d'ailleurs le
directeur technique national Christophe
main et l'entraîneur national Grégory
Baugé donc l'ont parfaitement dit le
travail a été fait notre équipe de
France est au point on joue à domicile
et je pense que secrètement quand même
on va essayer d'égaler sinon de de
battre ce chiffre de 2015 tout
naturellement mais nous avons une équipe
de France très forte et dans tous les
domaines en endurance
que sur le sprint et c'est ce qui fait
la force de se collectif équipe de
France justement sur le sprint l'absence
a noté quand même de Florian greenbaug
qui a été remplacé par Timy Gillian qui
est en plus un athlète original
territoire il est du club de du VCE Sky
Team vous serre c'est la mauvaise
nouvelle peut-être côté France l'absence
de Florian gringo non on peut pas dire
cela parce que encore
ligament croisée c'est bien ça bon c'est
dommageable bien sûr mais nous avons un
collectif assez fort et timide va tenir
sa place d'ailleurs la tenue lors des
championnats d'Europe tout à fait et là
dès mercredi soir avec de grandes
chances de médaille pour cette équipe de
vitesse par équipe avec Ryan est là et
puis surtout Sébastien Ligier comme chef
de fil et là faudra pas rater ce
rendez-vous mercredi soir cette première
chance de ménage mais Timmy a
parfaitement sa place et va tenir sa
place donc tout comme claracoponi et
puis le capitaine de cette équipe qui
est Quentin la Fare également tous les
trois sont du du club de
Sky qui vous sert et ça c'est c'est
vraiment très bien pour notre territoire
on a parlé des athlètes il y aura aussi
une première surveillée pour ces
Mondiaux de Florian Rousseau qui a pris
récemment le poste de directeur du
programme olympique Grégory Baugé aussi
qu'elle entraîneur du sprint ils seront
sous sous attention aussi oui alors ça
c'est c'est la bonne nouvelle ça a été
un choix voulu par la Fédération
française de cyclisme et tout
naturellement ce sont deux leaders
Florian Florian donc
champion olympique champion du monde
Grégory champion du monde donc c'est le
tandem qu'il fallait pour apporter donc
la dimension vraiment olympique à cette
à cette équipe de France et là c'est
vraiment là une très bonne nouvelle
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont apporté justement
cette équipe de France qui est assez
jeune il faut le rappeler une moyenne
d'âge environ 26 27 ans
la rigueur la rigueur du très haut
niveau et donc sûrement une prise de
conscience dans dans tous les domaines
bon il y a l'entraînement il y a la
récupération il y a le matériel il y a
la concentration et c'est ces champions
donc
on savent transmettre leur expérience et
face à des jeunes donc des jeunes qui
peuvent que écouter essayer de démontrer
qu'ils sont à la hauteur et ça c'est
vraiment le tandem qu'il nous fallait
pour donner franchir supplémentaires
pour cette équipe de France et ce sera
un retour de ces Mondiaux au Vélodrome
national après on se souvient d'une
édition 2015 réussi alors pour cette
édition 2022 c'est du 12 au 16 octobre
ça débute merci 50 délégations 420
coureurs seront sur place on attend
25000 spectateurs au vélo de route
nationale et on sera donc mercredi à 653
jours de l'ouverture des jeux olympiques
de Paris on peut le dire c'est un
événement test une répétition générale
avant ces JO formidable répétition bien
sûr et d'ailleurs beaucoup de nations
viennent repérer repérer les lieux
repérer la la piste avec les
particularités de la piste pour en tirer
tous les enseignements pour préparer les
JO qui sont
l'événement l'événement majeur mais
voilà et c'est ce qui fait la force et
tout l'intérêt de de ces championnats du
monde tout est prêt là on a deux jours
d'ouverture c'est mondiaux tout est prêt
sur place absolument là tout est prêt
tout est cadré et on doit rendre hommage
aussi à
la centaine de bénévoles qui sont
présents tous les jours aux côtés du
staff de de l'équipe de France et des
équipes de la Fédération Française de
Cyclisme parce qu'il faut il faut le
dire c'est un événement organisé par par
la FFC mais comment ça se prépare
justement ce type d'événement vous avez
parlé du rôle très important des des
bénévoles notamment comment ça se
prépare oui c'est toute une préparation
en amont avec avec toute l'installation
vous avez vu le l'air central qui a été
préparé au millimètre les podiums le
fléchage les abords et après bon il y a
il y a l'accueil l'accueil du public
l'accueil des délégations aujourd'hui et
donc c'est toute une coordination qui
est faite par le FFC mais sans ces
bénévoles et ce duo donc équipe
permanent et l'apport des bénévoles on
ne pourrait pas organiser de tels et des
événements les bénévoles sont très
importants dans le dispositif
d'organisation est-ce une épreuve à ne
pas rater si on a une à choisir là dans
les cinq jours de compétition c'est très
difficile parce que on a des chances des
médailles dans dans de nombreuses
dans de nombreuses disciplines bien sûr
mercredi il faudra pas rater la
poursuite par équipe mais c'est là la
vitesse par équipe il y a la poursuite
individuelle ou tout nous espoirs repose
sur quant à hermenault et bien sûr le
leader incontestable et incontesté de
l'endurance qui est Benjamin Thomas
champion du monde de l'Omnium faudra pas
rater l'Omnium il ne faudra pas rater
non plus l'américaine où il sera associé
à Donavan Grondin et voilà mais je veux
dire toutes les épreuves sont dignes
d'intérêt alors il est très difficile
d'en choisir une mais quand même
Benjamin Thomas devrait nous apporter de
grandes satisfactions peut-être sur ces
championnats du monde en termes de
médailles pour les Français ah c'est
c'est difficile bon j'espère que nous
allons nous allons égaler donc le score
de 2015
on devrait on devrait pouvoir faire un
peu plus peut-être un peu plus et au
niveau de l'organisation de l'événement
est-ce que l'objectif c'est de faire
tout aussi bien que 2015 voir mieux au
niveau de la réussite de l'événement se
souvient d'un événement réussi en 2015
oui il y a aucune raison qu'on ne
réussissent pas l'événement tout les et
tous les signes au sont au vert
actuellement en plus c'est un événement
qui avait qui va être couvert au niveau
médiatique d'une façon incroyable 30
heures de direct France Télévisions
Eurosport
relayée par une trentaine de télévision
dans dans le monde entier donc on peut
estimer pratiquement un son à 100
millions de téléspectateurs donc ça
c'est un événement porteur et porteur
justement pour pour la discipline de la
piste et pour le cyclisme en général
parmi les gens estacrité notamment
Michael elmidoro qui ne boude pas son
plaisir il reste quelques places quand
même parce que on a dit 25000 spectateur
attendu oui il reste encore des places
pour le premier jour pour mercredi
encore il reste il reste quelques places
mais après on joue à guichet fermé les
les trois derniers jours bon jeudi doit
rester encore quelques places mais là ça
se remplit je pense que les 5 jours
seront complet au niveau spectateurs et
toutes les infos billetteries sur le
lien bien sûr qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran je vous rappelle c'est mondiaux
de cyclisme sur piste qui s'ouvre donc
mercredi au Vélodrome national et c'est
jusqu'à dimanche merci Jean-Michel
richefort d'être venu en parlant plateau
merci à vous je rappelle vice-président
de la Fédération Française de Cyclisme
merci Mickaël également pour toutes ces
précisions et on va bien sûr suivre
c'est mondiaux de cyclisme sur piste on
vous reliera des reportages sur notre
antenne TV 78 également sur nos réseaux
sociaux ça sera mon camp de base le vélo
de route nationale de 50 ans et demi
pendant 5 jours avant de vous laisser un
petit mot encore une fois de météo
[Musique]
son octobre jour de la Saint-Firmin il
fera plutôt nuageux dans les Yvelines
comptées 9 degrés le matin avec pas mal
de nuages annoncés donc 9 degrés le
matin voici l'animation à qui s'affiche
ce sera à 15 degrés dans l'après-midi
avec des nuages également annoncés pour
le reste de la semaine dans le
département l'appui qui devrait même
s'inviter par moment à partir de jeudi
au niveau des températures ça ne devrait
pas descendre en dessous des 13 degrés
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition du 7
8 merci de votre fidélité on se retrouve
dans les prochains jours pour toujours
plus d'informations d'idées de sortie et
également d'infopratiques belle soirée
sur TV 78
[Musique]